Vernon can read well mr. Jordan worked
when he was in college in the summers he
worked as a chauffeur for a man who was
the sort of old-time segregationist and
once he was serving this man and his
family and he's actually he came upon
mr. Jordan and hit looking at reading a
book and he was shocked and he sort of
announced to his family Vernon can read
because he hadn't had anybody who worked
for him whom he really thought could
actually read a book I mean you know
reading a few things but actually
reading and Vernon can read and so he
always struck him as sort of emblematic
of how people underestimate blacks and
have underestimated him you know Vernon
can read and so he always said if I ever
write a book about myself that's going
to be my title so that's that's what
that was it was about his sort of like
this triumph over the kinds of attitudes
that suggested that he was not supposed
to do anything to be a servant went a
little bit serve it at that